[inaudible].
We're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty this week and joining me
today as a senior fellow at the Mercatus
Center at George Mason University,
as well as a professor of economics
at George Mason. Don Boudreaux,
welcome to the Rubin report. Happy
to be here. I am glad you are here.
I saw you speak about
a year ago in Dallas.
I want to get the exact title of
the speech right. Uh, it was called,
can we bring sound economic thinking
to Washington? That's a tough task.
That was a year ago and,
uh,
I don't think there's much sound
economic thinking or sound thinking in
Washington.
Forget economics for a second.
These things don't seem to
go together these days. Uh,
Washington seems to repel sound
thinking. It's, it's, uh, it's a,
it attracts on sound thinking. Yeah. Well,
you think it was always that
way or are we in unique times,
but we're definitely in unique talents,
unique times. So I was born in 1958,
so I came of age right when
Ronald Reagan. Right. You know,
at the end of the Carter administration,
when even Carter's
pushing for deregulation,
at least accepting deregulation
taxes were being cut airline to being
deregulated surface transportation
is being deregulated.
Reagan gets elected in 1980.
Milton Friedman has as popular
show on PBS called free to choose.
Uh, you know, Thomas, I'll learn about
Thomas soul. Everything seems very, oh,
this world's fine. Yeah. And
so in my life, in my life,
uh, there was a period in the past
when I was thinking was more sound,
I could quibble with it. Yeah.
But compared to today, it was,
it was outstanding because it's
definitely, it's definitely declined.
Yeah. It's hard to imagine even that
around the time of Jimmy Carter that
deregulation, I mean that, that Democrats
could have had anything to do with that.
And yet the Ted Kennedy was a major
force behind airline deregulation.
So there was, there was something,
I'm not sure what it was exactly.
It was something in the air, uh, starting
in the late seventies. And so, you know,
I was a young man then I just took it for
granted. Oh Wow. All right. This is fine.
You know, we're, we're
winning. It culminates in 1989
with the collapse of the,
of the, of the Iron Curtain in
1991, the collapse of Soviet Union.
And then here we are,
2018 and a lot of nonsense
is back on the front burner.
Nonsense is back.
So let's jump back though to the seventies
for a second because I watched an
interview with you this morning.
Something happened to you I believe
in 1977 that that woke you up.
And I think it sort of is a nice entry
into everything else that, you know,
I know said, yeah, I just
the most important day.
What happened to you in 1977 you can come
up with a couple of options. Yeah, no,
I know it was, the date was, was,
was, was was January 24th, 1977.
I remember there was a, um, I was in
college. I went to please my mother.
My plan was to drink beer, chase
girls. I did a lot of the former,
I wasn't successful at the ladder,
but I was going,
I was going to drop out of college and
work at the ship yard where my parents
worked. So I needed a class to fit my
schedule. I needed a Monday, Wednesday,
Friday class. I take this class called
economics, didn't know what it was,
took it and uh,
uh,
I had a great teacher and so she drew
supply and demand curves on the board and
she said,
look what happens when the government
prevents the price of something from
rising to its market level. It
creates a shortage. She says,
you remember the gasoline
shortages of 1973 or so? Yeah,
I was in those and I just thought the
beauty of this economic explanation for
the gasoline shortage was so spectacular.
I wanted to learn more about the subject.
And so in very short order,
I just fell in love with economics. I'm
still in love with it to this day. Yeah.
So tell me what happened after that. So
now you have your spark and what sort of,
what academic proceeds did you have
that got you to where you are in a very
lucky,
again,
she was a really good teacher and
it wasn't a famous economist at all.
She was a very good teacher.
She took a great interest in her students.
She taught economics as if
it was something relevant
to the real world rather
than just a mathematical, a puzzle.
Uh, and there was another guy at my,
I want to put,
it's called Nicholls State University
and Tibideau Louisiana that says it's a
very small school.
But I had another professor there who
was into Milton Friedman into higher,
uh,
into Ludwig von Mises into James Buchanan,
who later became my colleague at George
Mason. So I would go to his office,
his name is bill field,
and he would give me these books.
And so I remember just just
tearing through these books
and it just made so much
sense to me. I realized in reading
these books that all my life,
I didn't give much thought to politics,
not much conscious thought, uh,
but all my life,
uh,
I think somewhere deep inside of me
was a classical liberal or libertarian,
someone who believed that is basically
impolite to button to other people's
business. Uh, and, and, and, and,
and not only in polite, I mean it's,
it's downright, it's downright
offensive to do so. Yeah.
You just said to him may buzz phrases.
So classical, liberal and Libertarian.
Now one of the questions I
get most because I define,
I say that I am a classical liberal
if I need, if I need a label on it,
that's what I am.
And people will always say to me,
because I talk about many of
the things that you teach about,
about free markets and all that stuff,
and I believe that freedom is the
best way for humans to flourish.
People will say, Dave,
you're really a libertarian.
You're just holding onto this definition
of liberalism from 18, whatever.
Do you see a meaningful,
how would you define each one and
do you see a meaningful distinction?
I don't see much of a distinction. Depends
on who you talk to. Some people see,
see distinctions.
I think where they both have in common.
It may be distinctions at the margin.
Libertarians maybe tend to be a little
bit more radical. Uh, uh, but, uh, uh,
a what distinguishes classical liberals
and Libertarians as I'd have broadly
from almost any other political group,
a is the consistent,
uh,
believe that any exercise of power by
the state must meet a huge burden of
proof. Uh, the, the, the,
the burden of proof is not upon the
individual to make the case for his or her
freedom. It's upon the state
to make the case, to Intro,
to override that freedom.
I believe in libertarian
classical liberals as I think
of them believe that that
burden is a real one and it's a heavy one.
Sometimes it can be met,
but too often the reverse is in place.
People believe that you have to,
that the burden is on those of us who,
who defend freedom to make the case for
freedom. And I think it's backwards.
So basically you view it as sort of a
bottom up way of looking at things, right?
It's about the individual first.
And the government is not giving you your
freedom. It can take it away. However,
by instituting all sorts of policies.
Yeah. I, I'm in this case, I am,
uh, I think John Locke was right and
John Locke wasn't the only person,
but John Locke most famously, you
know, made the argument in the, in,
in the second treatise on
government that, um, uh, you know,
human beings have rights and human
beings delegate to the government,
uh, powers that you, that,
that those who do the delegation believe
are appropriate for the government to
defend those rights. Um, know we,
we can quibble about how historically
accurate that is, but I like, I,
I think that perspective is
philosophically correct. Uh,
no government gives me or you rights
governments are excellent at offending
rights and taking them away. Uh, but,
but just because government is to protect
her of rights doesn't mean he gives us
rice just because farmers,
uh,
because we couldn't live without farmers
if no one grew food. And, and, and,
and did ranching,
we would all starve.
That doesn't mean that we
owe our lives to farmers. Uh,
one of the great things about the
society that we live in is that it's a,
it was bit higher called the great
society to be distinguished from Lyndon
Johnson's great society. And
that is, it is a society of many,
many individuals each specialized
in doing various things.
We're all coordinated by the price
system and by the rule of law. Uh,
and so each of us makes a
contribution to the welfare of others,
but no one of us is utterly
essential. And that's, uh,
that's, that's uh, it's a really
good system, I believe. Yeah.
So I want to talk more about hiking a
little bit because you do run the cafe
high tech blog.
Uh,
you mentioned the burden of proof that
the government has to meet to say when
it's right to actually infringe on some
of your rights or basically do things.
Yeah.
So this is where I would say the,
the classical liberal and the libertarian
position is there a little bit
different.
I see some utility for the state and
although I'd usually want it done at the,
at the state level, not the
federal level. And Libertarians,
it's sort of hard to
pin on when it's enough.
And you alluded to that when
you talk to libertarians,
how do you get to a place
where, where it's not, you
know, I always make the joke,
it's like w eventually
you'll just be in mad max or,
or the true anarcho capitalists,
which I enjoy talking to,
but I view it as more of an intellectual
exercise than a practical. Yeah. I mean,
I, I'm very sympathetic to anarchical
philosophically I'm, yeah, but I'm not,
I'm not a, uh, uh,
a blow things up kind of guy and I'm
way too much of a hierarchy and to
understand that you just can't, uh,
uh, replace social institutions,
wholesale society has to evolve to
wherever it's going to be from being a
realist. I mean, you couldn't blow it
up. I fit well, yes you could, but, but,
but history has a lot of really telling
examples about attempts to blow up
society's wholesale. And those examples,
I've never turned out well in practice.
Uh,
let,
let me say among the people who will
call themselves classical liberals,
right?
None of them are ever at a w whatever,
express any sympathy for Anaco
capitalism among libertarians.
Some of them will say, oh no, I, I, I
believe there's a role for the government.
But you do it.
If people who classify themselves
as Libertarians who say at least,
at least in principle,
I believe that it's society could
exist without any formal institution of
monopolized coercion. And I, I
am in that ladder ladder. Yeah.
I might be the one classical
liberal who will do it or it,
that maybe by that definition I'm a
little more libertarian. But again,
these things all, yeah. You know,
it's really sort of the narcissism of
small differences that's exactly in this
little place. All right. So what
are some of the basic principles?
You're a professor.
What are the basic principles that
people should know about economics?
I know I'm giving you a wide one there,
but for someone watching this, that,
that's waiting for their 19,
77 moment. Yeah. Uh, so, uh,
in no particular order, number
one, scarcity is unavoidable.
We live in a world of scarce resources,
which means that if you use some
resources to do this good thing,
you take resources away from the ability
to do other good things in both good
things.
But we have to choose,
do we want to do this good thing or
do we want to do that? Good thing.
Second thing to note in order
to make that decision, uh,
we want the people involved who are
going to be affected both by the loss of
that which is not done.
And by the benefit of that which is done
to express their opinions. Honestly, how,
how valuable is this thing that we propose
to do and how valuable is this thing
that we propose to give up in order to
do this first thing? And then to do that,
we,
you,
you need people on the ground who are
actually affected by these decisions to
have a, a meaningful say. You don't
want a third party looking down,
making declarations. Oh, I
think you should have that.
And I think you should not have had that.
So any social mechanism that gives each
of us as much of a say as possible in,
uh, how we use resources and, and,
and make the evaluations about what w
what will happen if we use resources in
this way and what will give up if we
use resources in this way that that's
important.
Unintended consequences is
another important concept.
You know,
Adam Smith in the wealth of nations,
which is rightly considered to be the
start starting point of modern scientific
economics.
He,
he famously talked about the invisible
hand and this is a, this is this sort of,
uh, an unintended consequences
kind of explanations,
not from the benevolence of the butcher,
the brewer or the baker
that we expect our dinner.
But from their regard to
their own interests, uh,
they, they don't dislike you.
They value as a customer,
but they are doing their jobs
not primarily to help you.
They're doing their jobs to help
themselves and you are buying from them,
not primarily to help them but
primarily to help you and your family.
And in that way, everyone's either, so
this is a good unintended consequence,
but you have, you have bad
unintended consequences as well.
One of my favorite examples of
a bad unintended consequences
of the minimum wage
raise the minimum wage.
It looks like you helping low skill
workers and you might have some of them,
but in fact you're putting other low
skill workers out of jobs and you're
keeping them out of the job market
for longer. And so economists,
I think what makes a good economist,
which distinguishes a good economy is from
a bad economist or a non economist is,
is a consistency and asking questions,
always asking as compared to what,
as compared to what, where did that come
from? How are we going to pay for that?
What did this cost, uh, uh,
what will be the longterm consequences
down the road beyond the immediate ones
that, that everyone can
see. So it's just a,
it's just a consistency and asking
those questions. You know, it's funny,
as you're answering the question,
it keeps making me think, well,
this shows you why politics is so
screwed up because they get up,
they're all politicians on either side
and they either say $15 minimum wage,
Bernie or Trump, I'm going to cut
taxes on you. Or they, you know,
they love their bumper stickers stuff,
but nobody's ever said unintended
consequences in a presidential debate.
So how frustrating must that be as an
economist listening to people who are not
economists, who really aren't
experts in much of anything.
I don't know that Bernie has ever
created a business or made anyone make a
dollar off,
am not aware of it overnight.
But that must be incredibly
frustrating to hear.
Non Pros talk about the things that
you're a pro at. It is David and,
and you know, it's especially frustrating
about it. It's not rocket science.
I mean, I, I, I love economics.
I love my profession and I really
admire the best among my professional
colleagues, Milton Freeman High Tech.
Uh, but it's not rocket science.
It's just this consistency of always
understanding that there are consequences
beyond the immediate, uh, that,
that there's always a cost to something,
uh,
that no matter how
beneficial something is,
it has to be weighed against
that cost. So these simple, uh,
the simple understanding
and the consistency in
applying that understanding,
it's not difficult, but so few people
do it. So it is, it is frustrating.
Um, you know, years ago I stopped,
I joke that I stopped
watching the evening.
People my age used to watch the evening.
Even the news, right. I remember it.
I have some recollection again, I had
to stop watching the news have always,
always threatened. Throw my shoes.
Yeah. Through the, through the screen.
Because you know, the, the
reporters, they would very,
very much like the politicians. They
would report on the immediate effect, Oh,
the minimum wage is going arise that that
means that workers will get a raise of,
you know, whatever the amount is
as well. Well, no, it does it,
it means that for some workers,
but it means also other workers are
going to lose their jobs. Some jobs,
the nature of those jobs
are going to change.
Employers aren't just
going to sit back and say,
oh well we've got to pay
higher minimum wages,
so let's just pay higher than minimum
wage. Where's that money coming from?
Where are those resources coming from?
They have to come from somewhere. Yeah.
So basically your argument would be
that the government's only role in the
economy is to make sure we're not killing
each other. They're pretty much right.
Like it really it's a total
laissez faire at if, yes,
I am a very laissez faire guy.
If,
if property rights are
well defined and secure,
and there's a strong case that government
plays a role of Ken play a role in
helping to define and certainly
helping to secure property rights.
So that's where you're going.
Contract rights. Right?
So that's where you're not in anarcho
capitalists. Right? Well, I'm going,
I'm close to being here. I
mean, I, I'm, I'm willing,
I'm willing to admit that grudgingly
giving that to the governor. I'm willing.
Yes. I'm willing to admit
that anarcho capitalism, you
know, might not be, uh, uh,
ultimately a defensible position.
I am not willing to admit that free
markets are an indefensible position.
However, property rights come to be,
however, they are defined, however,
they are enforced when you have secure
private property rights and freedom of
contract, which includes importantly
the freedom to say no. All right,
I the freedom to not contract.
Uh,
then people are led to pursue their
people in pursuing their own interest,
are obliged to help others out.
And that's how this great society that
we live in and it is great, uh, uh,
continues to grow and become
more prosperous. Yeah.
So I mentioned to you right
before we started that, you know,
I've had a political awakening of
sorts and I always say to people,
I didn't really move,
but the left went so bananas.
I ended up being friends with all these
Libertarians and conservatives and
whatever, whatever it is, even
for the differences we may have.
But one place I have shifted is that I
am much more where you are economically
now.
And partly that's because I now run my
own business and have employees and have
to deal with that.
And I just wrote to obscene Lehigh
checks for taxes for the year. I mean,
we are in California.
You don't want to know him like that one.
It wasn't the federal loans even
worse than it's like you're,
the more successful I get, the harder I
work, the more they want to take from you.
And I tweeted something about that on
tax day and a lot of people were angry at
me and said, well it's, it's, this
is the price to pay for success.
Would you rather be poor?
And I didn't want to go on
a major tweetstorm and you
wisely or not on Twitter,
but could you,
could you give me something that,
if I ever get in that fight again,
I can say to people why that's not the
right way to think. So let, let, let,
let me start off though
with just asking you,
have you heard the story about George
Mcgovern when he retired from politics?
He a big snow please. So George
Mcgovern, when he retired from politics,
I think I have the details right. He
certainly had the, the major part of it,
right? He started the B and B, uh,
you know, in, in, in his home state.
You already like where this
is going. Yeah. And uh,
and then he encounters all these
regulations, you know, labor regulations,
safety regulations. Uh, and he admits,
I can't remember now to whom he admitted
as a long time ago. Yeah. He admits,
he says, you don't have to spend
all my, I'm not quoting him,
I'm going from memory. So I spent all
my life pushing for these things. I was,
I wasn't sufficiently attentive
to the downside of, of, of,
of these taxes and these regulations.
Yeah. And so it's easy to, you know,
to sit here in Sacramento to sit
in Washington DC to sit in some,
you know, local government, uh,
office building and tell other people
how to live and to tell other people how
much money they have to give to you.
And you can be well intentioned
in the best sense of the term,
but you are not those other people.
And those other people are
bearing consequences and
they know of things that you
don't understand. And so on, on the,
on the, on the, on the tax thing.
Uh, I like what, uh, uh, my
friend Ed Crane said about, uh,
the famous quotation that is above the
door of the IRS building in Washington.
It's a quotation from justice
Oliver Wendell Holmes who said,
I think there's an exact quotation.
Taxation is the price you pay for
civilization. And at crane says, no,
that's wrong. Taxation is the price we
pay for being insufficiently civil law.
Right?
That's a civilization is,
is when we cooperate peacefully to
help each other. And so even if we,
granted there is some role for government
and once you're granted some role for
government,
it's hard.
It's very difficult to not see that
there's some appropriate level of taxation
to fund that role for government.
Uh,
Ho Ho were much that may
be true that we need,
that it represents a failure of us as
a society to become fully civilized.
We've somehow not managed to figure
out how to cooperate peacefully and
voluntarily in those matters in ways
that we have managed to discover how to
cooperate peacefully in voluntarily and
doing what we're doing here today and
going to the supermarket
and the supermarket dealing
with the various, uh, uh,
suppliers that, that it has. None
of that is, is funded with taxation.
So all funded with voluntary voluntary
payments. That is civilization.
So I liked the notion that, uh,
uh, taxation is, uh, it's a,
it's sort of a measure of how little we
are civilized or how far we have to go
to be completely civilized to make sure
we're not killing each other to make
sure. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So, all right.
I want to get back to a couple of
things you said there. So first, okay.
I know the, I know that the minimum
wage is a, is a big one for you.
And even just this morning,
I write another story about how
Bernie wants this $15 minimum wage.
The anecdote that I keep using or
anecdote that I keep using is that I keep
trying,
I'm traveling all over the country right
now and in almost every airport you go
to fast food places and they don't have
people anymore. They have I iPads. Yes.
Now perhaps if you could pay people less,
people would have jobs.
It wouldn't be the
greatest job in the world,
but it would be the
way it's always worked.
Now we are literally replacing people
with robots that may be inevitable no
matter what. But to say that
you have to pay people again,
even from my own business here,
I get people offering to work
for me for free all the time.
I want to pay people appropriately
and we do pay all our people. Um,
but the idea that the government would
force me to pay someone x amount,
it seems completely bananas.
So the minimum wage, uh,
puts low many low skill
workers out of jobs. If,
if a teenager is not worth
$7 and 25 cents per hour,
employers who are not in the charity
business are not going to hire that
teenager at that price.
That teenager will go without a
job or go without a job in the,
in the above ground economy,
make find a job,
paying more in the underground economy,
which is a different set of problems. Uh,
and so that is the major unintended
consequence of the minimum wage.
There are others, but that's
the big one. Um, and if,
uh, you know what, people
like Bernie Sanders, I mean,
because I speak to proponents of
the minimum wage all the time, uh,
most of them, uh, do,
they just stopped the
analysis at the surface. Oh,
wouldn't it be better to be paid $15
an hour and said simple? Of course.
So this is, they don't want to get to the
unintended consequences part, I think,
because I think because most of them
believe that they just have this image of
employers as being a really rich,
uh,
highly profitable operations. And so if
you raise the minimum wage, oh, sure.
It has a cost, but cost that's going
to be born exclusively by employers.
But it's a fact. Most low skilled workers
work in highly competitive industries.
They work in food retail, they, they
work at lawn care. They, they, they,
they work in, in, in, in
supermarkets, restaurants.
These are highly competitive industries.
So there's no big profit margin there.
So when you raise the minimum wage,
it's not coming out of the
profits of the employers.
It has to come out of some change in
the way the employers do their business.
There's nothing wrong with automation
of course. Yeah. But there's a,
there's a proper amount of automation
and if you raise the minimum wage,
you get too much automation,
uh,
because you put a and too few
human workers. And here, here's,
I just want to make this clear.
Here's another unintended
consequences of the minimum wage.
And not only does it deny income to those
workers who will lose their jobs worse
in most cases, it denies those
workers. W what's even more valuable,
namely the opportunity to get that
first piece of job experience.
And so the 16 year old who otherwise
would have gotten the job without the
minimum wage becomes a 17 year old or
18 year old who's still a never employed
person. Whereas otherwise they would have
had job experience. And so it, it, it,
it swells artificially swells
the ranks of, of, of, uh,
unskilled workers.
Would there be a direct correlation then
that once you have this whole set of
people at this imaginary $15 minimum wage,
they are also going to raise prices
on basic things, right? I mean is,
is there a direct correlation that no
mean prices may rise a little bit cause
you get it,
you know,
the economy's a little bit less efficient
so you get a little bit less output,
but the price increases aren't,
aren't the, the major problem.
The major problem is employers will
find ways to satisfy their customers,
uh,
at slightly higher cost to the employers,
but at huge costs to those workers who,
who lose their jobs.
So when you've talked to kind of missed
on the left that disagree with you on
this and I, I get what you're saying
that they're not taking that next step.
I'm sure there's someone out there that
has made a sound argument that you just
disagree with you lay out.
So there is one sound argument,
one sound,
theoretically one theoretically coherent
argument for the minimum wage to
measure that one.
And that is if employers have
what's called monopsony power vent,
which I'm going to need to define
that one. Yes. Monopsony power is,
it's like monopoly power,
except so monopolist is the
only seller. A monopsony.
It's is the only buyer.
Okay?
So if you're the only buyer of low
skill workers in the market, right?
But you as an employer, you then
can, and it can be easily shown,
you can keep wages lower than
they would otherwise be too low.
And given that you,
it can be then shown that
if the government comes in
and sets a minimum wage,
right, then the, uh,
the employer will in fact pay the higher
minimum wage and no employees will be
harmed. But it's a very, very, uh,
strict criteria for this are very,
very strict.
And the idea that that Walmart and
Mcdonald's and Burger King and KFC and all
the mom and pop restaurants and,
and,
and made services and lawn care services
that we have throughout the United
States,
the idea that any one of these is a
month alone monopoly buyer of low skill
workers is just absurd.